كان رئيس مجموعه فاجنر يافجين بريكوتشين
قد اعلنت انسحاب مقاتليه من مدينه
اعتبارا من العاشر من الشهر الجاري وذلك
بسبب نقص الذخيره واتهم بريكوجين هيئه
الاركان العامه بعدم ارسال ما يكفي من
الذخائر الى قواته بقصد حرمانهم من تحقيق
نصر يعجز عنه الجيش النظامي وفق قوله
اتحدث نيابه عن نفسي وعن مقاتل فاجار
اخاطب رئيس الاركان العامه ووزير الدفاع
والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه والشعب
الروسي بالسادس عشر من مارس عام 2022
عندما لم تسر العمليه العسكريه الخاصه حسب
الخطه طلبت منا المساعده بعد ثلاثه ايام
وصلت وحداتنا من افريقيا مجهزه تجهيزا
كاملا وانضمت الى المعركه على الفور لقد
اعلنا حاله عجز الذخيره كنا نتلقى ثلاثين
في المئه فقط مما نحتاجه لهذا السبب كانت
خسائرنا اعلى بكثير مما كان ينبغي ان تكون
عليه لكننا واصلنا المضي قدما قبل شهر
توقفوا عن تزويدنا بالذخيره ولم نحصل الا
على عشره في المئه كنا بصدد الاستيلاء على
باخموت بحلول التاسع من مايو عام 2023
تزامنا مع يوم النصر وعندما راى
البيروقراطيون العسكريون ذلك اوقفوا
امدادات الذخيره ابلغ وزير الدفاع رئيس
الاركان العامه والقائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه رسميا ان رفاق لن يتكبدوا خسائر
غير مجديه وغير مبرره في باخموت دون ذخيره
لذلك في العاشر من مايو عام 2023
سننسحب من بخت